[Music]
and not looking good news oh so did by
Asian vs Mexican candy oh day one's all
fruity and soft thank you no one doesn't
taste like anything
well they'll taste like battery acid I
think the Asian candy has no taste to it
are pretty burnt from all the [ __ ]
you'll like hi to all the Scofield's
perhaps yes exactly researchers created
a life-sized doll of what office workers
might look like in 20 years
what but why they did also say we're
gonna have flying cars but what do you
exactly that means we don't have to work
no more dude we're about to be the year
2020 2020 everyone said then you picked
saying it the hardest way possible 20 I
know okay it's the future but but the
point is is that which was never rocket
cars all [ __ ] yeah Justin the
self-driving cars
well not exactly my mom was born in 1950
something that old [ __ ] uh-huh that's
old uh-huh that back then there was no
cellular phones call [ __ ] huh I think
so I just wanted to put into perspective
what an old [ __ ] she was I see is oh
she's alive my stepdad even older that
[ __ ] wrinkled old raisin he looks
like a [ __ ] melting [ __ ] hamster
she's let's roast them that's what this
turned into we're gonna roast we're
gonna go around and we're all gonna roll
being born at that era and seeing the
future like just the other day you know
that [ __ ] clear thing as people were
going through the airport I'm like Bob
we're in the future that clear thing
what's that one so clear is like TSA but
even better you walk through and then
they just scan your face and then you
walk through oh yeah
well like our phones we just open up the
[ __ ] phone by looking at it true
that's tight we're in the [ __ ] future
but I I'm so disappointed in the future
because when I was a kid I thought it'd
be so different the Jetsons really said
a heist and they did the bar that was
really sad but did you know how much
porn
we'll have free access I'd know that
that was not even imaginable to my puny
human mind the branding then I would not
part partially maybe why we haven't had
as many advancements
oh we're jacking off all day way too
much that's true I think so I think
somebody out there was gonna do the
flying car just can't stop jerking off
we could have cured cancer but that
[ __ ] nerd was jacking off all day
can't stop yeah
can't stop won't stop at least they
won't give up yeah that one that was
supposed to cure cancer me yeah but
you're watching on that porn I think it
was a combination of porn drugs and
[ __ ] playing games all day I think
for you as a combination of porn drugs
porn porn and baby started watching one
of these starts watching porn on this
phone it's too easy now you don't want
just about the big titty [ __ ] it big
dick people yeah the big titty big dick
actually no I watched that like five
seven years ago it's not a recent thing
yeah it's just recent to you guys for a
trend is [ __ ] incest or like brothers
that was four years ago everyone knows
that that was four years ago
Gina even knew that yeah everyone knows
that you don't watch porn enough okay
she's a mom dude moms [ __ ] moms watch
porn I think they make that baby each I
appreciate they don't watch porn what
mom's watch porn I think mom's watch the
most porn Barbie toy you accept that
your mom might even be addicted to porn
be jealousy oh come on okay have you got
it cool for you no sibling you know Oh
30 years ago you guys simply got a floor
watching big a big a horny you know that
they're old enough where they're past
that what's that menopause yeah thank
you busting up after menopause you can't
get pregnant you're done Paul for us the
factory shuts down all the positive
totally forgot it's right now I'm just
really sad I wonder if women get excited
because they're like afterwards they're
like you could come in all you want but
they're not
oh is that why the moustache like the
man's features yeah what a evil trick
God's plan on us right well no it's good
cuz it's supposed to stop you from
[ __ ] because you're not supposed to
procreate anymore oh yeah there would be
a cure for menopause but the guy who
would be working on is jerking off all
day yeah it's answered all the oh yeah
it's this shut down porn poor girl she's
killing off sorry everybody I'm chillin
she's chilling around yeah don't know
she's deejaying jacking off and Jill
enough and that's why there's Jack and
Jill bathroom so you both guys and girls
can jack off in there yeah never knew
that no no no it's a yeah it's pretty
legit
Joanna yep
damn - bump anyway we're talking about
the future we're office worker here has
nothing to do with porn or jerking off
okay show me a picture everything knows
but let me a picture please all right
some researchers made they created this
model of what the office worker would
look like in as little as 20 years the
human being or the environment human
being oh [ __ ] yeah
so they're saying let me guess like this
are hip flexors and be so tired from
sitting that they just look like this
all night they're sitting out all the
time your shoulders like this for
computer I was gonna look like Instagram
models they're hotter so they created
Emma because people are getting hotter
Emma which looks sexy like Oh farted oh
oh [ __ ] the future she just looks like a
fat girl now yeah that's why this will
just be like the norm even look at her
leg that's bad circulation she doesn't
move she has like stress induced eczema
and her arms but can she wear some
future [ __ ] like some some space Foilers
oh that's a nerd name yes and then her
eyes are like really red and dry and
like [ __ ] up cuz she's staying at a
screen all day oh you know what else
hasn't evolved past Deskin is really
white if I'm not being
she looks so [ __ ] bad so she likes to
[ __ ] go online like this one of those
years of just like yeah she looks
[ __ ] expired how she alive why did I
make her smile as what makes it creepy
yeah true that's all we need an exercise
do we need to exercise her wrists go in
the Sun a little bit stand up from your
chair yeah what they're saying is that
there's teachers that look like that
already
Sanna bruh no man I think every two
hours you want to stand up so put a
something tells us I ignore my watch
every Ally to stand up that's amazing
I'm like you're annoying
exactly no for real that's the ball
right there yeah for sure I heard that
we're gonna work work less hours in the
office anyway in the future because of
efficiency and robots robits the robots
because they'll be working for us
hopefully and then people are not gonna
have them in a job so they so
researchers surveyed more than three
thousand office workers in France
Germany in the UK and they learned that
50 percent of them complained of
strained eyes 49 percent of sore backs
48 percent of headaches 45 percent of
numb necks among other symptoms that
they blamed on their workspace I feel
like blue-collar work might even be
healthier yeah at least you're moving
around you're moving around or standing
up there talking to people probably got
like a bay door open got some sunlight
coming in I always liked blue-collar
work more than office work anyway hell
yeah I do too yeah my brother-in-law is
a plumber and they [ __ ] kill it they
do really well like you can make between
eighty and a hundred years as a [ __ ]
plumber risk to injury and all that and
you get tired when you get older right
but then there are some guys though that
are like still doing contract work well
into their 60s and 70s and to keep some
healthy it's like farmers yeah yeah our
new contractor he's probably like 60 or
something he moves around really good he
looks like he's in his forties
you got kids that are like almost 30
years old that doesn't matter
oh you Mexican I forgot his kids and is
this kids not in his thirties in his 20
no 30 no yeah he has a daughter that's
older than him
oh maybe by a year how does he have a
daughter that's all it again no no you
say the one year older than his own
daughter surpassed a baby so anyway so
this whole Emma project here it is
important to note that this report isn't
pure a peer-reviewed scientific study it
all mentioned by an office furniture
company oh god they're like you want
lumbar support you want you want special
chairs it's not blow your [ __ ] it worked
pretty much because they're saying that
pretty much like businesses need to look
at their work environment and they do
yeah and like actually make it
ergonomically safe for their workers or
chairs are these are economic they are
much better on these chairs than we did
on our other ikea ikea the $20 ones yeah
did you do like a thousand dollars did
you know there's there's this study that
terminally ill people in a hospital when
they have a window that they can see
nature have a much higher chance of
beating whatever their their disease so
like we're now in a hospital and you're
just like you just you look at another
building or just look at concrete jungle
or you're in a box you actually don't
heal that much so like nature is really
important yet you know i used to work at
a these they remodeled like the main
building of that hospital to create an
atrium in the middle of the hospital
Austin yeah
so they have like a hole cut out in them
are armed violence abhor wire to have
these calm feelings go when when we see
blue yeah so like the sky blue they also
have the does mute you know how are you
feeling here they have like sections
that you could remove they have ones
that it's like painted like the sky and
like it looks like flowers and stuff and
I you know I've been we need real [ __ ]
there's nobody at least that help has
been proven that like sitting like let's
say nine hours straight or whatever is
worse than smoking dude when I had
kidney stones a year ago that was one of
the most depressing months of my entire
life because I couldn't go anywhere I
couldn't [ __ ] do anything I was just
like inside all the time and in pain and
inside and in just going be able to go
no for a month did you look out the
window see some trees well sure but it
doesn't we gotta get that light on you
mean yeah like it but it was hard it's
hard to me to move around and I don't
like living in a cave yeah I mean you
have a fever
yeah Sun every day yeah that's true what
when I got my wisdom teeth removed and I
was indoors for like four days straight
and I didn't step outside at all I
started getting depressed and I started
thinking like oh my god is this my life
forever am I gonna look like a chipmunk
for the rest of my life and then finally
I was just like you know I need to get
the [ __ ] out of here so I went to go get
groceries and just that quick trip to
the grocery store I started got tired
home thousand times better no I started
feeling better I took ten steps now I
turned around and went to sleep
[Music]